so if you're looking to save money on  your next residential project well then  maybe i can help you here the easiest  way to save money on any development is  to simply cut floor area there isn't an  easier option than to cut out floor area  every single square meter that you add  into a project cost thousands and  thousands of dollars of cumulative funds  just because you add one square metre  doesn't mean that one square meter is  the same everywhere in the house so for  example a bathroom is going to cost you  three or four thousand dollars a square  meter versus a hallway which is a couple  hundred bucks but overall you really  want to be cutting out those substantial  square meter edges wherever you can so  think about your project overall think  about your project in specific minute  details